as promised colts running back nahim
heinz joins the program and nahim you
you guys had a good season got to the
playoffs gave the bills everything they
could handle i know every team says
we want to win the super bowl but you
have to feel like the season all in all
for the cults given the expectations and
just kind of the uncertainty around the
franchise it seems like it was a success
uh definitely we have uh this year we
definitely have nothing to hang our
heads on but uh the way i look at it and
a lot of people look at it is uh we did
fall short of our goal and uh though it
wasn't this year we could win the super
bowl we're definitely uh in the right
direction we're gonna take
we're about to keep making steps to you
know go towards the super bowl and
that's our goal
did you sense during
you guys have already had a ton of
changes uh in the off season what are
you gonna miss most about philip rivers
uh just the uh
the competitive nature he brought every
day and just doing the right thing and
being a pro i love watching to play
cornwall i love watching him shoot free
throws and uh just love how he woke up
every day just as hungry
as a guy like myself and he's done
everything that he could possibly
imagine with all his accolades
you you've also had the change obviously
an offensive coordinator
how much do you
how much interaction have you had with
marcus brady and what do you expect from
him and how's the offense going to be a
little bit different
it's going to be a great offense i'm not
exactly sure how marcus has spent on it
yet but marcus has been uh he's been in
our he's been in our facility been been
around and been the brains a lot of
things he's in that quarterback room
with frank uh nick siriani and philip
and every quarterback that's played so
uh i think uh everything's gonna be fine
and marcus is a very very intellectual
guy so i think our office is gonna be
great he's probably gonna have his own
little spin to it and we're gonna go out
there and execute it
you know i mentioned the playoff game
against the bills you guys
you had your way with them offensively
450 yards no turnovers did you sense
during the game that the bills were
the players were kind of a little
nervous that you know this magical
season they had may come to an abrupt
end
um i don't really think so not not much
uh we might have had them on their heels
but you know it's a four quarter game
and i'm sure they came out knowing with
us even throughout the highs and lows it
was gonna be a fourth quarter game and
uh just looking back on the game and you
know the season we used to make the
plays that we needed to make to win and
uh that was like evident with a lot of
our losses so that's really been our
focus just you know coming back next
year and figuring out how like you know
the good teams make those plays and how
we can be a great team who's gonna make
them play so we're gonna make sure that
we
execute when it comes to it
do you have a little wish list you carry
around of guys that you hope will be
quarterback of the team next year
uh
no um
honestly truthfully not uh i trust in uh
you know chris ballard and jim mercy and
everybody in our staff to make the right
the right choice for our team they've
been doing a great job and we've built
together a pretty great squad over the
past three years with uh coach frank
ranks so i think whoever we bring in
they're gonna be great for organization
and we're gonna go out there and try to
make him look good too
you played with a lot of quarterbacks
nahim and you kind of came into your own
in in your rookie year when you made
that great catch over the honey badger
from andrew luck do you ever see andrew
luck coming back and playing again
oh absolutely not i don't i don't see it
at all uh i actually saw us i actually
saw espn talking about earlier this
weekend i think uh truthfully andrew's
probably
happy with his decision and if he
doesn't he'll come back but i think uh
andrew
he has a wife and he has a kid who's
over one years old i think he's enjoying
that enjoying the retirement right
so you don't even have a favorite
quarterback you want to see on your team
next year if you could pick it
uh
no i i honestly would especially with
having uh this be my fourth quarterback
in four years i've just learned not to
have any favorites i just i've learned
uh whoever comes in there i just need to
make sure i'm at my spot
at the right spot at the right time for
my play honestly
uh nahim jonathan taylor had a great
rookie season uh really came on strong
near the end especially had that huge
game toward the end of the regular
season 200 plus yards how much did you
work with him how much did you help him
especially when you know coming into the
nfl you're not used to playing as many
games as you played at the college level
how much of what we saw from him was a
result of you kind of helping him get
through that rookie year
oh uh
[Music]
not much i you know i gave him my little
my
my advice and i told him how important
his body is but uh i think it takes a
village to you know raise everybody and
i think jonlin's play was just you know
everybody in the organization invested
in them the line blocking it blind
blocking heart for him and uh you know
all the guys like myself jordan marlon
being himself and helping him uh be who
he is he's a great player and uh he was
always going to be that so i don't
really think i had anything much to do
with that i think he put the work in he
listened to the right people and he's
been working hard
hey nahin before we let you run tell us
what you have going on with mda
uh this year i'm honored to be the uh
2021 national spokesman of india mda and
muscular dystrophy association
where you know i'll i'll do my best job
to rate to raise awareness and uh you
know just make people more aware of not
only muscular dystrophy but als and all
the other 43 neuromuscular diseases and
a saint patrick's day i'll be honored to
help with you know the mba shamrock
program the largest st patrick's
day fundraising event so you know we're
going to keep just working hard and
even if you're not affected by anybody
with muscular speed you can always you
know reach out and help and uh fight
this fight that we're all fighting
together
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports